if you're like me you want Kate to wipe
your memory so you can enjoy gen VV all
over again sadly it doesn't look like
things turn out well for our eye
bleeding soup in this final genv preview
breakdown we take a deep dive into the
trailer which hints at who might be the
newest member of the seven what will
happen to our heroes and some potential
connections to the new season of the
boys for those wanting to know where to
find this trailer I found it under the
extra section of genv on Prime Video in
Canada I'm hoping it's available
internationally too it's only 35 seconds
long but has some juicy footage that
hints at how the season will end but
before we begin make sure to like And
subscribe and definitely check out my
massive 25-minute long episode breakdown
there are tons of cool details and
theories that go beyond the show well it
looks like the final villain of season 1
will be the consent Queen herself Kate I
mean she's just killed the dean so it'll
be pretty difficult to come back from
that our first shot is of her entering
the woods notice how her eyes are not
bloodshot here here contrary to how we
saw her at the end of episode 7 this
would suggest that this is happening
prior to the death of Dean Shetty
remember that the dean's final
assignment was to have Kate kill
everyone in the woods while they may
misdirect us into thinking that she's
actually here to free the inmates of the
woods something we'll see later on what
I'm really curious about is whether or
not any of these inmates have the virus
Dr cardosa told us that in its current
form it can only be transmitted via
bodily fluid so so even if the inmates
get out which they do we aren't dealing
with a full-blown Wuhan situation out of
curiosity where does one even get into
the woods is this elevator attached to
Dean shed's office it probably doesn't
matter I'm just wondering Kate tells the
others when I'm done maybe eventually
you'll realize I'm being a hero so it
appears Kate is just getting started in
whatever she has planned remember that
she told them that soups have to strike
first Kate also seems to subscribe to
the professor Brink definition of a hero
that being a hero a real hero is not
about
Glory it's about sacrifice this is a
little different than what her
ex-boyfriend Golden Boy said about being
a hero being a hero is uh it's not what
you
think you know if you're going to do
this make sure you do it for you so it
seems like this theme of what it means
to be a hero will play out in this final
episode Sam looks to be the only one in
the bunch to join Kate it's kind of
ironic considering he almost killed her
in episode 6 and she was the one
responsible for wiping his brother's
memory of him last episode we saw how he
was radicalized by Rufus towards this
Pro soup sentiment we're better than
humans my guess is that Marie and the
others let Sam and Kate leave without a
fight at least for now we'll later see
Marie telling Jordan in that very room
that they have to stop Kate but it
doesn't appear like a big Showdown will
happen here at ched's Emma doesn't want
Sam to go they've built up this romantic
relationship over the past few few
episodes and judging from what Sam does
later in the trailer I'm not sure this
is a relationship that can be salvaged
check out this shot of Andre am I crazy
or does the background look like it
could be a hallway at VA Tower it's a
bit of a stretch since he'd have to go
back into the City and come back to
campus now it looks like Andre could
have a meeting with VA CEO Ashley
Barrett about becoming a member of the
seven in The Season's crossover video we
get this little snippet of a clip we
need to send someone straight to the
seven if if you look closely you can see
what appears to be a resume or file with
none other than Andre Anderson the
boardroom here looks like it could be
the same one we'll later see Ashley in
at the gulan campus it also appears that
the campus is put on lockdown we'll see
students try to escape as these giant
metal doors lock them in Andre showed us
how every door and window can be shut
like some sort of prison now that we
know gulkan was created not to train
soups but to monitor them it begs the
question is this to keep people out or
to keep the students in now I went back
and looked at every dorm room and
couldn't find this one with these
rackets on the wall perhaps it's just a
cutaway to show that the dorm will be
put on lock down what appears to be a
guard's hand presses this red button
we'll see a guard follow Kate and the
other inmates Out of the Woods no doubt
this guard has been pushed by her just
like she did to Woods guards in episode
to so this pressing of the button could
be an initial alarm when the woods are
breached or it might be a button to
release the prisoners it might even be a
larger alarm that locks down the dorms I
love this shot of Kate breaking out the
other inmates just how many inmates is
unknown but I counted at least five but
the thing that concerns me is this
sweaty guy is this a side effect of his
soup power or could he potentially have
the virus and bring it out into the
world I'm sure I'll be corrected in the
comments if I'm wrong here but from my
understanding Kate only learns about
this virus in episode 7's final scene
it's just hard for me to believe that
that Kate would knowingly bring someone
out who has the virus who could
jeopardize all soups now take a look at
this guy in the back right in this shot
here we can see what appears to be blood
splatter on his shirt suggesting that
some sort of battle between them and the
guards takes place the guy on the right
here has holes riddled all throughout
his shirt all I can think of is that
these are bullet holes like we've seen
from the guns held by VA guards who
fought Sam we can also see that Sam is
here too this must be a freaky thing for
him returning to the prison he was held
at for years Jordan and the others plan
to stop Kate and Sam which also means
stopping the inmat so expect a big
battle we'll see one of the inmates with
a laser eyes just destroying everything
in her path as she makes it topside
Marie makes it into Dean shed's office
not exactly sure what she's doing here
unless there's some sort of entrance to
the woods or something that she needs to
find it's here that Marie experiences
what appears to be an earpiercing screen
both Ashley Barrett and Adam Bor
experienced this too we'll see the the
windows crack here suggesting that this
is indeed some sort of auditory attack
is this coming from one of the new soups
found down in the woods a device that's
been rejigged like the guards used in
episode 2 or could Kate's Powers have
expanded now that she's off those meds
remember that Kate has been on these
pills for years and that they've numbed
her powers will we see the full extent
of her power this episode now that she's
unencumbered by this medication Sam and
Adam Bor have a little confrontation of
what appears to be the studio I'm not
exactly sure if this takes place before
or after Adam makes his way outside
alongside Jordan Ashley and Ashley's
assistant who is literally named also
Ashley before we get to the final battle
which seems to take place outside we'll
see polarity and Andre it's left a bit
ambiguous whether or not this is
polarity squeezing his son's hand or the
other way around this is one telling
shot with it cutting to a shot of Marie
concentrating it highly suggests that
Marie performs her first head pop just
like her new BFF Victoria Newman again
this could be an editing fake out but I
think it would also make narrative sense
if the season ends with Marie performing
her first pop but whose blood is this if
we're going with the head pop Theory it
pretty much leaves one person and that's
Sam we do see him trying to kill Andre
if it isn't a head pop Kate could be
reacting to any number of things she
could be injured or something bad could
happen to Andre we'll see Sam here
clinching Andre's neck since we're
outside the main campus Building and see
Andre using his powers to reach for
something I think it would be ironic if
he bashed Sam in with his father's
statue we'll see Sam use his super jump
attack here and notice what looks to be
a dead student just chilling out by a
tree one of the most interesting shots
here is of a metal door from the woods
closing on Sam it's weird because it
appears someone is locking themselves in
the cell and Sam is the one in the
hallway I'm guessing this has something
to do with Kate and Sam's attack on the
woods the final shot is of this VA
helicopter crash landing well will see
that its blades are completely destroyed
notice the VA symbol on its side
suggesting Ashley or another character
from the boys might be a board the
feeling I got is that Andre is trying to
save the helicopter so that it lands
safely if he ends up saving the CEO of
vot's life that definitely would make
him a contender for a new member of the
seven but Andre is still a junior and
it's likely he'll be in season two of
gen V could he simultaneously be a
member of the seven and a 10 gulan or
would this be something that would
happen after his final year showrunner
Eric kryy stated that the end of season
1 of genv will tie into the beginning of
the boys season 4 so far we have Ashley
the seven Victoria Newman and the virus
which could all factor into events of
the boys I for one am really looking
forward to the finale but now I turn it
over to you what do you think will
happen in gen V's final episode I want
to hear your thoughts and theories in
the comments below thanks for watching
please make sure to like And subscribe
and if you haven't checked out my
episode 7 breakdown be sure to do so and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram @ thinkstory YT
until next time remember holy
a lot is
happening